ladies and gentlemen please give
thunders applause to Tom Scott very much
so in the very first talk today Warren
Ellis said that predicting the future
was a mug's game so there's been enough
history today let's try and predict the
future you don't really notice change
happening um Google was incorporated 16
years ago yesterday 1998 um the easy
access to information that it uh sure
did changed the world and sure if it
hadn't been Brin and page it would have
been someone else with a similar
algorithm but can you imagine taking
someone from 1996 never mind Victorian
times with Hillary just 1996 and showing
them today a small little magical device
in your pocket that can answer 99% of
all your questions about the world and
99% of all your requests for media but
that reports your location to the police
constantly says they can look you up if
you need to and then you've you know
you've got any number of instant ways of
communicating with people around the
world nearly anyone in the world all of
which is monitored all the time by
shadowy government agencies what they
think we're in a dystopia would they
think we're in some sort of each other
whether it would be somewhere in the
middle so let's plot a line let's plot
line all the way over here all the way
over here is 1998 the founding of Google
right here in the middle is where we are
now 2014 let's see what someone from
1998 would think about today because
what I'm going to do is go about 16
years into the future into 2030 and
let's say that we have roughly the same
orders of magnitude increase in access
to information let's propose some
slightly fanciful technology that is
about as fanciful as Google would have
been all the way back over there let's
do a talk from deconstruct 2030 and it
would start a look at something like
this teenagers are becoming telepathic
privacy is dead and we're in another
tech bubble
welcome to 2030 or at least one possible
2030 for the best technical folks in the
audience it might be a little bit
difficult to work out what is in the
heads of 30s teenagers walking down the
street earbuds in throat mics on
muttering to themselves constantly
emotions flashing across their face
faster than seems reasonable and anyone
who joins an engine network right now
with no prior experience will find it
overwhelming it takes about four or five
days of constant access before your
brain starts to get used to the enormous
tidal wave of data that hits it every
single second most people particularly
those over the age of about 30 will give
up within about four or five minutes but
there's a reason you hear testimonials
from the people who've stuck around
about slowly becoming telepathic what we
have today is a confluence of two things
first and foremost engines Lynn and
xiaoning's
paper now legendary in computer science
it's difficult to remember now just how
difficult it was to get information
before Ganymede came along in the early
days of Google the same as the early
days of Ganymede
it wasn't intuitive it was a difficult
process you forget now that originally
you had to actually type you had to
spell things correctly you had to load
the right data you have to give it the
right hints and ease it through the
first stage of the process so Ganymede
and the other engines could go work out
what you were asking for it wasn't
intuitive it was something that like
typing that you just had to learn okay
you don't learn typing anymore but once
more time that was important but it was
still a Lightspeed leap forward before
Ganymede if you if you want to go out
with your friends to a restaurant you
want to find somewhere you would have to
open one app to find a restaurant and
then you would open a second app to see
if it was any good and see if it let you
die for requirements and your budget and
then you open a third app to see if
there was a table I mean more than that
you might actually have to use an
old-school webpage for anyone remembers
those
well you could try and wing it of course
plenty of people did but if you wing it
too you were likely to be disappointed
and no one's disappointed anymore
Ganymede and later the other engines
ability to take petabytes of images text
video anything and to infer truths to
infer partners to infer faces and
dialogue and anything from them in real
time that was a that was a jump on the
scale of the mass printing press on the
scale of Google no one believed in the
mid-90s that a search engine could could
realistically pull in results from the
entire web and send them out in real
time not realistically couldn't be done
in the mid tens no one thought that a
search engine can realistically answer
questions like where should we eat
tonight not pulling the meaning of we
and and eat and work out what you're
actually asking and yet here we are
Ganymede aloud the orders of magnitude
increase in access to information
lemon jamming had the perfect
combination of philanthropy and business
acumen they released the engine
algorithm as open source that's what
sparked the engine explosion that's why
throat mics actually started working but
they tempt there then incredible exabyte
of structured data of inferences of
patterns to themselves and to their
company but that on its own doesn't
explain the muttering teenagers the
second part of what we have today is
it's more a social change really one of
the key points about engines is that the
more open you are the more information
you give them then the better they are
that's why those of us who remember
privacy don't really get as much out of
them I mean yes okay we keep throat mics
on at work we take them off when we get
home but the idea of allowing any third
party access to everything we say
everything everyone we meet everything
we do every where we are is is abhorrent
the idea that we should do that it's
just wrong I remember clearing my
cookies every day ask your parents um
now most of us we we suck it up we deal
with it because the results are worth it
but the payoff that we get from being
open is worth what we perceive as a cost
um but we still take a throat mics off
when we get home I mean how I still use
a keyboard every now and again to write
code some of us still have to even as
typing becomes a more and more niche
skill the only way to stay connected to
everyone in your social circle right now
no matter which engine you use no matter
which particular company runs yours the
only way to stay connected to everyone
is to be entirely open that's the only
way that the engines know which of your
thoughts to send to other people and
which should come back if you remember
the Facebook newsfeed and later the
Twitter newsfeed remember the fuss that
caused you remember how it prioritizes
information that was more important to
you well I'm offline right now at a
conference but as soon as I walked off
and put my earbud back in then my engine
will start catching me up at 800 words a
minute faster but faster than anyone
could possibly speak of but that's still
slow enough for people to understand for
the brain to understand and it will
start catching me up just on the
important things just on the things that
matter to me that's what those mushroom
teenagers are doing as they walk down
the street they are talking to a
thousand people at a time mediated not
by an artificial intelligence just by
algorithms they talk to the world and
the world listens and they listen back
they are taking part in and now a giant
20th century chat room 18th century
coffee shop it's something much greater
than the sum of its parts certainly I
was I was telling the worst case
scenario scare stories about flash mobs
buckin back in the tens and we haven't
seen the start of it that's the crucial
part of entrance you give and they give
back all of those engines all those
engines talk to each other one talks but
ok now the companies that control the
engines have data sharing agreements
between
each other because it's not a good idea
to run for more finds these things if if
it needs to the little engine on my
phone that I carry in my pocket it can
access the down links from the military
drums hovering over Brighton circling
30,000 feet ok the outsourced privatized
military drones hovering over Brighton
at 30,000 feet um maybe it needs to
guide me past an obstruction maybe more
likely it wants to magically route me
towards a friend or maybe wants to
magically route me away from a cluster
of people with as bones or whatever our
bones are called now or maybe it just
wants to answer my question about
finding a pub where I can see the Sun
setting no one's asked that question yet
in exchange for me knowing that right
now then other engines from the
government and the police can see what I
am Who I am what I'm doing and what I'm
gonna be up to and they know everything
about me but I also know everything
about them those of us who weren't able
to make that sacrifice don't get to use
engines that's not a choice that's the
same way having a smartphone wasn't an
option
neither is not having an engine
connection I mentioned people with as
opposed by the way we've we've seen a
lot of press about those excluded by the
algorithms Cory Doctorow who is is up
next
talked about Wafi in his book down out
in the Magic Kingdom a magical currency
based on reputation score now he wrote
about neural implants and brain backups
and essentially an automated system that
worked out what other people thought of
you and used that as an actual currency
ruse telling me we heard this referenced
earlier maneki-neko it was it was used
an example plausible deniability early
but it was it was artificial
intelligence that was mediating that a
network that actively attacked people
who were trying to bring it down and
made their lives very difficult what we
have is so much more mundane than either
of those options so much less explicit
your engine notices the time that it
takes you to to respond to things
notices the reactions you have to people
notices whom you avoid and your biases
start to get
taken on by the engine and it was
designed by engineers in Silicon Valley
in John one can so as Fox News so
delicately put it and I apologize for
the accent well as some folks it just
don't work so well on give member the
racist webcam they don't see that from
2009 there's an HP laptop with an
automatic tracking camera which and it
wouldn't follow you unless and I'm
quoting here you had enough difference
in intensity of contrast between the
eyes and upper cheek
yeah it's that but worse because all the
all the implicit associations all the
hidden biases that study after study
after study after study have shown art
in everyone's heads they get picked up
by engines the fact that college
professors are more likely to respond to
inquiries from men picked up by the
engines it's not clear enough to
quantify it's not clear enough to defend
against it's not one thing you can pull
out of the enormous web of connections
and patterns that the engines pick up
and you should have seen the fury when
one CEO said well that's the way it
should be
engines should reflect the biases of the
people who own them and then what about
the people on the other end of the scale
the people who were the people who want
to be popular or don't want to be
popular we were starting to see
sponsored lives back in 2014 just the
very start of it the people who were
yeah I hated the word back then the
people will blogging the people are
talking into their webcam once a day and
uploading their lives and their thoughts
and their experiences and kids teenagers
kids younger than that but flocking to
these people and old media television in
particular couldn't understand it why
why would you want to just watch someone
talk into a webcam and they were trying
to ask that even as they were updating
their antiquated reality show formats to
be ever more and more artificial
Saturday night entertainment 2014 BBC
one celebrities during acrobatics now
wonder the kids flocked off to YouTube
nits successes and now one of the
advertisers went with them straining
life logs of course have been tried
for years back in 1996 was arguably the
first one the first real-time feed that
was pre Google but the trouble was with
the exception of some obsessives and
folks who were happy to watch people
play video games 24 hours a day you
still need an editor no one has time to
watch lots of people's entire lives so
he still needed an editor to package up
the highlights tell a story work out the
details and put it together for
consumption
well engines can do that powered by
measuring attention responses constant
automated a be testing and all its
successors they can do that they did it
almost everyone born after 2010 is now
providing a life log for their friends
and if they're good at it if they're
popular they providing it for an
audience beyond that as well no wonder
they they're the ones getting
sponsorship and product placement and
for advertisers there are no limits on
how sneakily or subtly you can start
putting product placement into there
the regulation hasn't caught up with it
yet at all it's notable that there are
people folks in the news folks
folks who really don't want to be there
they have that audience even though they
really don't want it there used to be
that concept of the a-list celebrity and
the zedla celebrity of course the idea
that Hollywood and movies and television
and gossip magazines they were the
arbiters of who was a celebrity and who
the public cared about that was the idea
right you know you you appear in a movie
you appear on television you are in you
are part of that celebrity that's not
how it works
now celebrity doesn't work celebrity
works like the music industry used to
I'm sure everyone knows that a folk rock
sea shanty band is not going to make the
top of the radio on playlist the friends
of mine that played Glastonbury they're
really good but that's fine because they
know that a folk rock sea shanty band
isn't going to be there they're not
aiming for that they're aiming for the
portion of their audience that likes
folk rock sea shanty bands they're
aspiring to be the greatest folk rock
sea shanty band they can be that's what
they're aiming for that's what their
audience wants and as the music industry
always was they can talk directly to
those people who can get the fans they
can
target and niche that's how celebrity
works now you can target a niche doesn't
matter you may never be Hollywood a-list
celebrity but doesn't matter maybe
you're more interested in it's always
videogames some form of videogames some
specific form you can aspire to be the
celebrity player of that particular
genre and you will find an audience and
they will know where you are and the
advertisers will follow those have seen
the dangers of this haven't we
it's cardinal richelieu is quote suppose
you'd quote give me six lines written by
the most honest man in the world and
I'll find something in them to hang him
which has never been more true we've
seen modern engine technology used by
oppressive governments just as often as
we've seen it used to take them down
yes knowing the identity of every
protester in a mob he's devastating
knowledge but it will not stop that mob
storming the gates of your palace if
they're already there it's a little too
late we've also seen what a mob of angry
bitter keyboard vigilantes will do to
someone that's offended them when they
really do have access to every aspect of
your life hiding from abusers from
stalkers is significantly more difficult
than it ever was there is no off button
no block button for face recognition
technology
despite the use ham-fisted attempt to
force one into law politicians
politicians
positon found that that not only other
current lives open to detailed analysis
but that previous ones are to Facebook
survive long enough to get its data
hooked into engines just long enough and
of course your privacy settings don't
matter all that much when every tourist
photo you've ever appeared in is now
available for download as well doesn't
matter whether you tagged that as
removed elites in this photo because
that doesn't really apply anymore when
all of your users have blanket access
and just give it over well your life
from the advent of smartphones onwards
is perfectly searchable
Tom even claimed I was young I was like
mid-20s at that point and even if
somehow you managed to come through all
that squeaky-clean without a stain on
your character without a bad picture
anywhere can you claim that for every
one you were ever associated with
everyone you've ever appeared next year
can you can you say for every word you
ever anonymously wrote on every web
forum anywhere that all of those were
fine when IP address logs which are in
the engines and throws analysis which is
pretty easy to do can trace it back to
you with 95% accuracy we're at
panopticon now where they're placed for
everyone who lives in a city or uses
anything other than the postal service
and that's 85 percent of the UK
population and rising
have you seen the crime statistics
pretty much every type of crime is down
in the last 10 years it's not a
statistical blip it's not under
reporting the percentage of crimes being
underreported so the percentage of
crimes going unreported has gone down
too and yes as a methodology for that
you can look it up
I know correlation is not causation I
know that the two don't go together but
if you go out into the street and just
ask people people who grew up post
Google if they would trade everything
that the last the last 16 the last 32
years has given them for some nebulous
concept of privacy you are gonna wait a
long time before you find someone who
thinks that's a good idea and if you
talk to the kids who grew up post
engines then privacy's this strange
thing that their grandparents believed
in why wouldn't you share exactly what
you're doing does it's just the right
thing to do imagine for a minute that
you are sitting back here in 2014 the
day before Lennon jamming released that
paper nothing seems to have changed for
a little while
the last big revolution back in 2014 the
last big revolution was
Twitter and that was eight years old
it's ancient history there was just
enough complacency just enough thought
of stability as they came out of a
recession that they'd gone and got
themselves into another bubble apse this
time smartphone mouse previously back
then it was the dot-com bubble but now
perhaps there were companies investing
billions in just little little toys on
phones they never get their money back
they knew somewhere they must have known
they were never going to get their money
back but it meant that their competitors
weren't getting that little toy on the
phone and maybe maybe they make enough
money back with advertising or whatever
idea they had that they could start to
make something out of it that's exactly
what's going on now engines one bit the
engine I used the engine those muttering
teenagers news has just been bought for
twenty billion dollars it'll last what a
couple of years the investors are
banking they can make that money back in
that time and they won't make their
money back just like last time and just
like the time before that but my point
is not to complain about people being
people and making some poor investment
choices and my point is not to mourn my
old-fashioned ideas of privacy because
even back in 2014 that ship was sailing
and it would have taken an incredible
effort to stop it forever sea was
already dead it's just that not everyone
agreed with it yet my point is not to be
someone from the previous generation
complaining about muttering kids and
their damned distractions of course
they're distracted they are part of what
may be the greatest thing ever to happen
to this planet my point is this the
dot-com crash all the way back then did
not kill comms the app crash did not
kill apps not the concept and killed a
lot of individual workers but we're
still using them the engine crash won't
kill engines but you're sitting here and
you think the world is always going to
be like this everyone does I do we've
always had engines the same time we've
always had smartphones back in 2014 if I
think back to my time in university I
had a smartphone then I just remembered
no I didn't and I'll brick of a Nokia
because that's when I went to universe
but my brains kind of casually edited in
that of course we always have
smartphones but here's the thing it
might not have been engines might have
been anything might have been nanotech
or biotech or some weird thing I can't
think of even now predictions of the
future never ever turn out to be true
but that next thing whatever it is it is
right around the corner
it always is no matter what year it is
whatever that next thing is will change
the world and it will arrive so fast
faster than anyone can think but it
won't be shocking it won't be startling
it won't plunges into a horribleness
taupe your elevators to a glorious
Technicolor future world the same way
that our world right now isn't really
either of those things whatever comes
next will change our lives and we have
the choice to shape how it'll change our
lives but it will change them and those
lives will by and large get a little bit
better just like they usually do so
whatever that next thing is
and whatever year it actually turns out
to be hope and whether you to see it my
name is Tom Scott enjoy the rest of the
show
you